[Music]
caitlin is with us in san francisco hi
caitlin welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi dave hi rachel how are you guys doing
great how can we help
[Music]
um so my brothers and me um
the total money makeover for christmas
and i read it two days
so that was fantastic wow thank you
yeah um unbeknownst to me i had
kind of already been working on some of
those um baby steps
but now i've kind of hit a couple
questions
that i might i need a little help with
okay so um the first one's kind of minor
and you could probably just
spit it out real fast for me um when it
comes to
the envelope system when i if i have
anything left over at the end of the
month
what should i do with that should i roll
it over into
um the next month should i throw it
towards that should i throw it towards
savings yeah caitlin if you have that
extra cash i would definitely throw it
back towards your debt if you still have
debt if you've not saved your thousand
dollar emergency fund you can use that
to help build it up
but if you're still in debt and you have
extra money in those envelopes yes take
that extra and throw it at the debt
now the only time there would be an
exception to that would be if it is a
category that you don't spend monthly on
and then you can use your envelope
system as a little miniature savings
account
so like as an example uh i buy clothes
once every three years but
but some people people say but very few
people buy clothing once a month
shopaholics do but most people don't buy
clothing monthly
so your clothing envelope could bleed
over from one month to the next
unless you're rachel okay but uh but uh
the uh
so if you don't spend all your clothing
money go ahead and still spend it on
clothing in a different month
by keeping it in there car repair would
be another one of those
but the ones that rachel's talking about
are like groceries well yeah and most of
your envelopes are going to be those
things
your envelope system really is for the
categories you tend to overspend on
meaning you're spending it consistently
so if you're not spending it on clothes
i may not even have a clothing envelope
you could just have that in your budget
and know
but when you actually go to the bank and
cash out money that's usually going to
be
for things like groceries groceries is
the big one yep
or we have a horrible habit on spending
money
on eating out and that's where i'm like
okay
this is that budget needs to shrink
drastically yeah so and so if that
envelope had money left in it
i'm with rachel i throw that at the debt
yeah because you're going to refund
because
you're going to refund that the next
month and that rewards you for not
eating out so much
same way same with going to the grocery
store if that's got money left in it
but if it's an envelope and stuff that
is not a monthly occurrence necessarily
you can let it bleed over to a different
month and
and obviously and we said this in total
money makeover questions
uh the uh um can you get her back i'm
sorry caitlyn
your other question was what you have
another one yes i do this is the the
more major one
um so my husband and i are both in
school he's a full-time student i'm a
part-time
student and we have two boys and because
of the pandemic i'm kind of
homeschooling them
and so our paycheck has kind of taken a
hit
and we're actually really on the um
rice and beans kind of diet um so
um we don't have any car payments both
of our cars are paid off and we don't
have any student debt so
yay for us however um we
are living with my in-laws and they plan
on moving in the next two years and
about a year and a half they're planning
on retiring and they're moving and we
don't want to move with them
we actually have a plan to move out of
state to a complete like cross country
and so my big question is where do i
in my step two process where do i kind
of
put that on hold and move towards
building up my emergency
fund for the move planning for the move
it's a moving fund it's not an emergency
fund
and so what i would do is budget for the
move figure out what's going to cost you
and then stop everything in time to save
that money
so my my question is right now i'm not
paying rent because i'm
rooting with my in-laws but when we move
we will be paying you so that's why i'm
like you'll be paying rent out of an
income you'll be
you're not going to rent something for
more than your income will cover
you don't need savings for rent okay
that's going to be coming out of your
income it'll be part of the budget
budget
okay so where are you going to move and
would you go back out in the marketplace
if you move
um so we will be moving to wisconsin
um and i i didn't quite catch the
section so
and will you be going back to work
oh yeah we don't actually have like
jobs lined up on the other end and
that's why i said it would wouldn't be
more of an emergency fund because
you need jobs lined up before you make
the move you got 18 months
yes don't move without the job my
husband well
my husband is getting his degree um he's
working on his bachelor's degree right
now and he will actually finish
the summer before we move like we plan
on moving before
right after he completes his degree okay
well that makes sense
all right so yeah make sure you're
paying cash for that but don't uh
go we're going to move and have six
months of savings set aside
because he doesn't have the job get a
job
and then make the move because if
there's not a job in wisconsin then
there's a job somewhere else you might
not even be going to wisconsin
but my touch 22 dilemma is that my
my in-laws are moving i know you've got
to move out of that house
but you're not moving to wisconsin
without a job
you might be moving to a rental down the
street or you might be moving to austin
texas i don't know where you're going
where is he going to get a job
and that's a big deal i mean he's got to
really start talking about that now
let's go ahead and start planning that
out and start start
courting with some of those companies
and figuring out where you're going to
land
the idea of just moving over there and
hoping it all works out
uh that's a bad idea you need that lined
out
and the good thing is caitlyn you have
you guys have time you have time to
prepare exactly
which is which is a blessing so use that
time and that way you don't just fall
off the cliff